here to discuss what all of this means
I'm joined in the studio by Richard
fitzwilliams public relations consultant
and World commentator and talktv
contributor Paula Roan Adrian always
great to see you both and going to Mike
Paul first president and CEO of
reputation doctor down the line joining
us from the US this evening Mike we'll
we'll start we'll start with you is it
is it where you sold on this these
reported sources saying that Harry and
Megan are kind of done with being out
there
oh whenever you say you're done for life
I always have a warning for any client
that's in that kind of a situation but I
think we need to remember the two pieces
that really tie to why they were upset
in the first place and it was tied to
remarks about their children and remarks
that were filled with race really racism
if those two issues are off the table
dealing with the Royals and of course we
know historically that's not how it's
gone
then I think they have an opportunity
but I think we need to look for the
future to still have those two issues
discussions of the children that might
not be something that they accept
especially from a race perspective and
of course Harry marrying a woman who is
biracial and race always being a part of
the issue I think you raised an
interesting point that is worth
remembering where this all comes from of
course from Harry's point of view as
well he always brings up obviously his
upbringing what happened to his mother
those are the reasons he uses uh you
know in his long-running battles with
the press and with the media as well I
want to come to Paula in the studio to
react to some of what you've said there
might do you think that's fair Paula
that you know that is what will keep the
discussion going um the children and the
race issues and of course the press and
the press's reaction because let's not
forget that when we have a story like
Megan and Harry it's the press and their
ability to manipulate that story
manipulate the narrative I think that's
what's going to be pushing this so for
example you spoke about in your
introduction about the Privacy we saw
the South Park clip about privacy
nowhere in Harry's speech when he
finally said afraid we've got to go guys
nowhere did he say in that speech I am
going I'm leaving the royal family I'm
leaving this country to lead a private
life that's not what they said in fact
they said the absolute opposite they
said they wanted to continue their
charitable work they said they wanted to
continue the Royal Legacy because they
weren't able to do that and we also have
to remember that this is a family this
is a man who lost his mother and wanted
to protect his wife a wife who has
received death threats real death
threats people are in prison now serving
sentences for those death threats of
course he wanted to and needed to speak
out so Richard let's come to you on this
because that is what Paul is pointing
out it's a battle between the media and
the sussexes here and what is the
ultimate resolution and often the
complaint that you hear contrary to what
Paul is saying is that they have
demanded that they be left alone and yet
they still keep putting themselves out
there well firstly the idea of the
silent sussexes it's an interesting
concept but I certainly don't entertain
much hope that we are going to get it
because there are several issues
involved here now the first one
regarding spare which I have to say I
wondered who'd advised Harry the issues
such as how he lost his virginity the
drugs issue which is going to be raised
in court in the United States as to how
he entered and so forth and then of
course a penile frostbite that sort of
thing I mean I wondered saying how many
people and how many Afghans he'd taken
out that was extremely ill advice you
wondered who was fires again but on this
particular issue what we're seeing
is very much someone who's I think a
campaigner now he believes that with
regard to the press as you were saying I
mean it is something that he feels very
deeply about he actually believes it's
his life's work is called it to clear up
the cleanup the what he sees is the
origin Stables of the British media
there are several court cases now less
than five three of them against media
groups either about to start or having
started and what we've seen is I think a
very very
bitter Harry but on the other hand don't
forget the contract with random house
because here's another danger of the
royal family for one second think that
they sussexes are necessarily implicated
because they haven't received the
apology they hoped for
it was a four book deal we've been told
with random house Megan could write her
memoirs Harry could have a book out of
the 800 Pages we only had 400 in the
span he could write about his childhood
so we've a lot to play for so to speak
yes in the international Arena concerned
look coming back to Mike
um what you're thinking when you're
hearing all of this I mean so far we
haven't had I think any extreme views
which you sometimes get in debates about
sussexes of sort of just everyone just
wants them to shut the hell up
um we're hearing pretty balanced remarks
here about the press and the
relationship with them
well I think it's important to
understand some key terms like leaks
that's what those cases are about so
let's be accurate about why Harry is so
upset and he wants the world to
understand quite frankly how the
tabloids work in the UK with a lot of
leaks even from family members releasing
some of those leads and that was also in
the book The the comments that recently
came out about having a different View
and saying we're done with it was really
about attacks that dealt with race
children and various crisis issues that
were tied to the sepsis not everything
so let's not throw the baby in with the
bath water and say that they're not
going to speak at all they're never
going to come out of the house of course
that's not what we're talking about and
yes there are different kinds of books
that can be written and they can also
produce things for Netflix and not only
be the Stars a bit in defending but I
would say this
I don't think Harry and Megan are ever
going to give up the opportunity and the
responsibility to defend themselves and
their children if they have personally
attacked with lives and that I don't
think that is ever going to end and like
they're perfectly entitled to do that as
you said and they are private
individuals and they have a certain
amount of celebrity brand of course I
want to ask you from your reputation
specialism point of view do you think
it's been a successful Rebrand for the
two of them in the US and here in the UK
to date no and the reason why is the
root of their brand especially Harry's
that trips into Megan's and to the
children is at its core right
not American
not a reality star not a defender of
various things that he's even gone
through in life if your brand at its
core is one and you take that away
your brand is damaged what you need to
do is leave open the opportunity of
potentially like someone have said in
the media most recently that you might
rejoin the royal family and phones that
you might still move back to the UK that
you might still have a Mia culpa that
earns your way back into the royal
family in a very different way quite
frankly the way that the king had hoped
that it would be
original Mike uh gonna come to the
voices in the studio because you've got
two uh people here in Britain shaking
their head vigorously to some of the
things you're saying and I think it's to
do with Paula Harry coming back to the
UK and his relationship with the Royals
I did want to slightly disagree with
Mike on this one because remember we had
the people's princess yeah Diana took a
very bold move and she left and she not
only left the royal family she left this
country and we were told that that was
absolutely her plan was to to to live
away from this country and in effect
it's sad to see that Harry has had to
say take that same path in order to do
what he thinks he needs to do to protect
his wife and coming back to this issue
this relationship with the Press
ultimately it I was intrigued at the way
the story was being sold today oh he's
finally going to stop talking oh he's
finally going to shush oh he's finally
not going to say anything the Press
aren't going to leave him alone the
Press aren't going to leave her alone
and anytime they dare to open their
mouths about anything thing she
straightened her hair Rosanna yeah and
it and it made fun of course it's
important business
apparently it is
so important in the enormity of the
brand it's very interesting because when
one's thinking of how well they're doing
the extremely controversial near
catastrophic car chase which I think
much of a horrible experience there's
absolutely no doubt and there's no doubt
it brought memories of Diana back I mean
the paparazzi in my viewer lower Richard
you agreed that it was near catastrophic
because there were roads necessarily
then some Recollections may vary on that
point yeah but indeed none of us were
there but near catch a story was the
wording they used and it was debunked a
little bit certainly hasn't been yeah
tough as the exact title but what what
interests me is the positively frenetic
media interest worldwide in them and
there's absolutely no doubt us Harry it
goes through these various court cases
is we also as I said we could see
further books as far as Netflix
concerned we saw a six-hour document
series which I don't think was
particularly helpful although it wasn't
desperately harmful but spare was uh him
going spare as I saw it and those
interviews as well all so many were so
damaging to them let me ask you from a
subjective point of view Richard because
you've watched the world for most of
your career do you want to see Harry go
silent and disappear would you think
that would be better for him I don't
think that he and Megan have any
intention of doing that but but I want
to see what I want to see is them
ceasing to attack the royal family
because what we've had is a form of
Guerrilla War over a period of time
since they stepped down and it began
without and subsequently of course we've
seen a lot of it recently but the thing
is the palace can't fight back not
easily at the moments they fight back
sources say sources say sources say and
the palace fight and they fight hard the
palace can't make statements and if they
can't make States there's always the
problem is the sixes then can control
the agenda and that is what the superb
in doing and that is what I fear it's
got this Rift here it's going to go on I
wish it had never happened believe me of
course yeah you know there are
subjective points on this there are the
facts and there is everything else and
there is a reputation of brand issue
we've been very pleased to be joined by
Mike Paul in the US this evening on this
as well as Paula Richard here in the
studio thank you so much for joining us
for this talk now